at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking don't question my cybernetic
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton hello ladies and gentlemen
and welcome back to the tim ferriss show
what you're about to hear is part two of
a multi-part conversation with Roth
Potts author of vagabonding world
traveler extraordinary one of my
favorite people if you didn't catch the
first part you might want to do that
before venturing in but if you don't
mind your story's is more of a jigsaw
puzzle then by all means keep on
listening we bounce around a lot it's a
very eclectic conversation so you could
certainly listen to these things out of
order this episode is brought to you by
99designs so you can check out a bunch
of my competitions that I've run at
99designs com forward slash Tim and
ex-officio and if you want to see some
of my favorite pieces of travel gear as
well as a video on rapid ultra-light
packing then you can visit ex-officio
except for shou ex-officio dot-com
forward slash tim and i almost forgot of
course there are a ton of resources and
links and websites and books mentioned
in this episode all of it can be found
in one place in the show notes so you
just have to go to 4-hour workweek com
all spelled out forward slash podcast
4-hour workweek com forward slash
podcast you can find the show notes and
resources and links for this episode as
well as every other episode like those
for Peter teal Tony Robbins Mike Shinoda
you name it so you don't need to
scribble furiously unless you want to
but for our work week dot-com forward
slash podcast is where you want to go
without further adieu and further Porky
Pig imitations please enjoy part 2 of
the Tim Ferriss show with Rolf Potts
what are some of your favorite books or
commentaries on writing well this is
funny because I writing in various
context I have a teach at a summer
writing program in Paris and then I'd
been doing a class at Yale the last
couple years and so I've been reading a
lot of craft books recently and I
realized that I had crossed my carrying
capacity that I needed to stop freakin
reading books about writing craft that
like I had learned all the metaphors
there that there were and so I mean
there's some there's some
journalistically minded books like Roy
Peters Clark has the writer's toolkit I
think it's called and Phillip low-paid
has a book called a collection of essays
about the writer's craft called to show
and to tell I think because you know the
old adage goes show don't tell but he's
a believer in the idea of strategic
telling and he's a brilliant essay as to
spell his last name
lopa te got it he's sort of the modern
father of the Belet ristic essay the
personal essay and he he actually came
up from New York to talk to my students
in person earlier this year and he's
kind of writing is very different from
what what you and I do and he might sort
of frown on it to a certain extent that
he's really about that old going back to
Montaigne high art of the essay but he
really has some good advice on writing
and jumping back to screenplays the
breakthrough for me and my writing when
I took my first vagabonding trip and
thought I was going to be the new Jack
Kerouac and tried to write about it and
realize that one chronological retelling
of what I did was not gonna work
regardless of how beautiful the
sentences were was stumbling into
screenwriting 20 years ago and learning
the importance of structure and so those
classic screen write its homes like you
know the Syd field screenplay book or
Robert McKee story which is actually
ridiculed in the movie adaptation right
yes I think Cox actually plays Robert
McKee in that movie I think that those
are useful because they go back to the
very core
of how we communicate as humans how we
tell stories and you can get tired of
the three-act a screenplay structure or
the needs of the audience but the the
audience is damn important and I'm a big
believer and you know I'm not a believer
in cultural hierarchy I think that the
high literature is important and good
but I mean I just wrote a pulpy b-movie
III I think that that it's good to know
how Raymond Chandler structures his
narratives in the same sense that it's
good to know how Montaigne structures
his narrative as well so I would say if
people are looking for writing craft
books don't be afraid of any kind of
book that just talks about how to tell a
story and I think that movies are great
metaphors for how to tell a story and
there's crappy movies out there and you
know adaptation it's sort of a Lampoon
of how we invert ibly tell stories in
movies but just because you learn a very
basic and formula what formulaic way of
say telling a cinematic story doesn't
mean that you have to use that every
time it just means that you understand
the rules and then within the structure
of those rules then you can shine as a
writer I very much concur I have a
embarrassing confession which is I've
been agonizing over a screenplay for
several months now and I think partially
because I've loaded I've loaded the
expectations and the burden so large on
my shoulders it's it's roughly an
adaptation of the 4-hour workweek in a
lot of the backstory and it's intended
to be comedic but instill or at least
convey a lot of sort of philosophical
takeaways that hopefully will spur
viewers to do interesting things in
their lives and make big changes blah
blah blah but I've been agonizing over
it the one thing that did help me to at
least get started and I have quite a lot
on paper was save the cat I thought that
was I don't know I've seen this book but
I found it so helpful because I also
read I took Maki's story seminar
actually witness which was a quite an
experience in and of itself
the the portrayal and adaptations not
far off the mark but a fun experience
nonetheless I really found save the cat
to hold your hand and walk you through
at least getting things down on paper by
saying are right by this page in this
minute you should have this type of
element and really allowing you at least
to get I wouldn't consider what I have a
first draft but a skeleton structure
down that I can use to fill in the
blanks with all these random ideas that
I have totally agree I think that you
know become recently interested in in
Joseph Campbell had a passing
familiarity with Joseph Campbell watched
a few documentaries but the hero's
journey and the these the monomyth I
find very interesting just as a way of
getting started if you can sort of lay
out these markers for different stories
that you're considering telling but you
know another another thought that I had
which we don't have to go too deep into
unless you have thoughts on it but is
that that beginner's mind that you
mentioned which is achievable through
travel or vagabonding is also I think
one of the primary benefits of what you
might consider therapeutic use of
psychedelics and that's be part of the
reason that people often describe with
the right set and setting a psychedelic
experience is one of the best
experiences of their lives is I think
the same reason that many people would
describe their first vagabonding
experience as one of the best
experiences of their lives and that's
the present state awareness and the
beginner's mind and the appreciation
that both of those experiences tend to
catalyze but yeah yeah what I touched on
that a little bit in vagabonding I sort
of gently dissuade readers of the
necessity to say smoke marijuana when
they travel because reality is giving
you this present state awareness you
know if you allow yourself to be bored
or if you allowed yourself to be lonely
or just if you allow yourself
have experiences by accident then
suddenly you're having you're
discovering things in a vivid way that
don't need artificial enhancement
definitely I uh the the one of the
pieces of advice that you gave I'm
pretty sure that uh you gave this advice
that I feel free to to to correct me but
was getting lost the benefit of getting
lost and heading out of your your
housing whatever that might be and just
walking off in one direction maybe with
a map maybe without a map and just
walking and taking random turns for a
few hours
and I have found that so invaluable not
only while traveling quite frankly but
even in San Francisco and places where
I've lived or live exploring by foot a
terrain that you might otherwise for the
sake of convenience use taxis for for
instance and it's it's been I think a
major priority for me when I travel not
for business but for this type of
experiential reflection and exploration
to to try to catalyze discomfort
whenever possible and that doesn't mean
a pebble in the shoe but to for instance
to purposefully go out of my way to
encounter language difficulties and one
of my favorite ways to do this I'm
typically a night owl like I mentioned
but when I travel I try to switch it up
so I'd like to try to wake up in some
cases very early and I did this in
Greece my first trip to Greece I was
traveling with a close friend and I
started waking up really early I would
just leave the blinds open and I'll wake
up as early as possible and my habit was
to to go for a walk and just hand wave
and try to ask the locals these were on
some very small islands where I could
find a cafe or a bakery and inevitably I
would go to these bakeries or coffee
shops and there would be a small group
of really old Greek guys sitting outside
debating what whatever old Greek men
debate I would imagine it's probably
complaining about politicians and so on
and so forth
much like every other sort of gaggle of
old men early in the morning everywhere
else in the world and then I would just
proceed to kind of sit down and try to
have a conversation with these guys and
it was always hilarious and extremely
fun and I ended up being basically the
court jester for these guys for for a
period of time in the morning and they
always got a kick out of it so I think
that I mean I've said that that that's
seeking out of mild discomfort or
uncomfortable situations I think is is
really one of the main values and
benefits that I've taken away from from
travel in the last certainly the last 10
years or so yeah this ties into a lot of
ideas that are really close to my heart
and then that I've sort of embraced even
since I discovered vagabond it's fine
that you talk about the old Greek guys
because as a travel writer one of my
biggest strengths and it could be an
accidental strength as a person who
wanders out with purpose of getting lost
is that whatever town I'm in inevitably
the town weirdo finds me like the most
eccentric I and if you read my second
book Marco Polo didn't go there like one
third of the stories are about me with a
really strange dude in Lebanon or Burma
or someplace and it's sort of connected
to the idea of the old Greek guy sitting
there is that they they see each other
every morning but the chance for an
American to stumble in and sort of have
a semi comical exchange with them is the
most exciting thing that's happened to
them all week you know it's like their
wives have stopped listening in to them
their children have stopped listening to
them and so they can take you under
their wing and just the things that you
learn from these guys is amazing and so
that that's funny that that's that's
very relatable because I I feel like for
whatever reason I don't know if I if if
it's my Midwestern tendency to talk a
little bit less and maybe listen a
little bit more or something that I
always meet these guys who just have the
weirdest view of the world
you're talking about walking out and
getting lost in vagabonding I talked
about how if in doubt just walk and tell
your day becomes interesting and then
and this is sort of tied into a concept
that I've discovered since then and as a
concept set that I teach in my Paris
classes because we're in the city where
is invented and it's the idea of the
phone or are you familiar with the Flynn
er the only reason I'm in passing I want
you to expand on the only reason I word
is because a friend of mine named Nassim
Taleb who's very famous for having
written the Black Swan der yeah and
number of other books describes himself
that way
yeah and so maybe you could expand on
that because I would love to hear more I
quite frankly I don't know much about
the term it's it's a wonderful idea that
in a sense when I was walking until my
day became interesting I was being a
philanderer before I knew what it was
but it goes back to to Baudelaire in in
you know over a hundred years ago in
Paris and it's connected through French
ideas through the the Situationists of
the 1960s and the idea is that and
flittering is something that I use in
travel but was really invented as a
concept in your own hometown and the
idea is that you become so used to in a
nerd to your hometown that you're not
seeing it anymore
that has become a purely utilitarian
space and between point A and point B
you see it's living that in your routine
you're not really living your routine
you're just sort of in this is a
paraphrase but you're sort of zombie
walking through your day and so being a
full neuro faloona is not someone who
walks through his own city in in a
utilitarian or pragmatic way a phoner is
someone who goes out in search of
experience and there's someone it's also
tied into the idea of psychogeography
that instead of walking through a city
with the idea that you're gonna say see
tourist attractions or that you're gonna
go to visit your friend on the other
side of town is that you're gonna walk
through the town psycho geographically
and you're gonna can collect the color
red and you're just going to see how
many forms the color red
can take we're gonna look for every
parking meter in town where you gonna
look for license plates with the letter
Q on them cool are you gonna look for
every immigrant restaurant and that that
is gonna organize your day that
psychogeography
the being of lenore is even less
structured in that you're just you're
just wandering and it's a wonderful it
was invented to be done in your hometown
to break out of your own habits it's a
great thing it's a great way to break
out of your tourist habits where you go
to a city and there's a hundred thousand
things you can do in a given moment and
you do the obvious thing which is go to
the tourist attractions and I'm not
gonna knock that there's a reason why
their tourist attractions but people
talk about how oh there's the beaten
path
everything's been discovered everything
has already been done and it's like
actually that's not true you know Paris
is the most touristed city in the world
but you wander for ten minutes and
pretty soon you're gonna be finding
something that's unique to itself even
along the strands all these they even
know that Sean dumar with the Eiffel
Tower is if you just embrace the idea of
the flah Noir and walk until something
catches your eye and stay open to
experience instead of your plans then
you're going to you're gonna be living
in a way where you previously had only
been consuming those moments and flaner
is Fla n you are as all right that's
right with a little hat over the a got
its got my five of all the languages
I've attempted although this one very
half-heartedly my I just cannot seem to
get a grasp on French because I panic
when it starts to erase any of my
Spanish or confuse anything else that I
studied but Paris what is it like to
teach in Paris and art what type of
students are you teaching well I teach
it at the American Academy I'm actually
the the course director and it's sort of
become my baby I've been running this
writing workshop for the last ten years
on roofs on Jacques in Paris and my
students are like age eighteen to age 70
and it's just it's a large number of
people some people are there because of
they know vagabonding or my writing or
they know some of the other writers who
teach there I have to one other
nonfiction teacher and two fiction
teachers so it's not just travel writing
they can study poetry or
screenwriting or short stories and so a
lot of people have just it's it's sort
of a bucket-list thing for them is that
they want to come to Paris and be a
writer for a month and it's and it's one
of the exciting parts of the program is
that it delivers you're there on the
left bank you're in the University
District of Paris and you're you know
you're you're firing on all cylinders
that you're you're writing all the time
you're interacting with writers you're
reading a lot and you're being a flow
nura is and this it's funny that I
discovered the flitter in the context of
Paris even though I'd already been doing
it and even when I'm not teaching travel
writing the Flint is such a great
creative exercise for my students who
might be writing a poem rather than a
travel story and even wah talked about
how a city like Paris is sort of like a
house that's been wallpapered over so
much that the only thing holding it up
is the wallpaper is that there's no
everybody's written about Paris and so
you have to find a way that is against
expectations and the only way to find
that is to get out and wander and find
your own interests you know and I've had
students who have brought their
skateboard and through skateboarding in
Paris have discovered sides of it that
nobody else is seeing and they've
discovered you know the French
skateboarding culture and so yeah my
students are just there for the romance
of Paris and the great thing is that
it's a great you know July in Paris his
romantic place to be but it's a great
place to deliver you know you can walk
outside of a classroom and in 90 seconds
you're where Victor Hugo lived when he
was 11 years old and so there's this
huge in three minutes you can go to a
place where Hemingway got shit-faced you
know like we're literally we're on the
street you know that he describes you
know in moveable feast and so I think
that energy I mean it's like we could
teach the same thing in North Dakota and
it would still be very professional I'm
very proud of what our teachers are
doing but there's it's almost like a
catalyst Paris puts people in a mental
state almost like an athletic
performance thing is that people are in
Paris and they're not going to blow it
you know right they don't live in Paris
they're gonna come to Paris and they're
gonna do something special and it
creates this energy that that amazes me
every year of people just uncorking some
really
some really good stuff and and just
having some going back to time up just
an experience that is that it's very
specific and very very Parisian but very
unique to themselves so I've really
loved my association with that city that
sounds amazing how many students are in
the course it varies from year to year
we've been averaging about 24 it's
capped at 32 and so how do you can wear
from 18 to 32 students I feel like I
should take the course sounds amazing
I fairly frequently about going to
graduate school or attempting something
like an MFA for creative writing because
I really haven't ever explored fiction
outside of Elementary's doing some
exercises in elementary school what do
you find of the students who take this
course what are the carrot what are the
shared characteristics of the people who
get the most out of it and I'm going to
leave that open-ended on purpose but I
think it's it's an earnest desire to do
their best combined with sort of a
humility almost a beginner's mind type
humility towards writing and sometimes I
can get a very young and brilliant
college student who will come in sort of
a leg above maybe sort of a mid-career
professional but because the college
student is has not quite cultivated it's
it's it's a strange thing to think but
there's a sort of confidence and
self-assuredness that college students
have that like a mid-career professional
doesn't have and that can get in the way
of the beginner's mind and so that sort
of know-it-all is a wrong word but like
the overconfidence of a brilliant
college student might impede his or her
advancement were like someone who's 35
or 45 and is just there to soak in and
everything and work as hard as they can
I think it's the person going back to
the beginner's mind it's the person
who's willing to embrace the beginner's
mind and work hard and synthesize the
creative aspect with the parts of Paris
that you can't overlook you can't just
come to Paris
sit in your room and write all the time
any more than JPMorgan should have been
reading teletext as the whole time you
was in Egypt that that interactive going
on having fun and having a bottle of
wine by the Sen and flittering through
the city and discovering things by
accident is gonna feed what's happening
when you're alone in your room and so I
think it's the students who can find
that balance and and the students I
think to a big extent it's the students
who have been in almost like vagabonding
who've been saving their money and this
this means something you know that
they're not just gathering from their
limitless pool of resources to pay for
their month in Paris but they have
earned this with their sweat it's like a
chapter in vagabond I talked about how
the work you do makes your travels
meaningful I think it's the people who
come in and know the value of what they
have in Paris that this this one month
is a special time that can catalyze them
into a new creative State those are the
people who are gonna we're gonna get
things delivered for them and you
mentioned MFA's I got a mid-career MFA
and I know there's there's some
advantages of that sort of thing but I
think there's an extent to which that
creatively a one-month program like this
can cover a lot of those MFA bases
without compromising two years of your
life right right right right greed I
mean I'd love to hear your thoughts me
my basic fueling is that the benefits
would be and I mean it's it's maybe
sounds ridiculous that I feel very
isolated writing a lot of the time and
it's it's it's sort of odd that I'm you
know access to more people and I've ever
had access to in my life yet I spend a
lot of my time feeling quite isolated
and lonely and there's and I don't know
many writers in San Francisco I just
that's not in my social sphere which
maybe is a good thing maybe it's a bad
thing but the idea of being in a group
of people going through the same
experience having that shared study
experience I'm sure with some degree of
commiseration every once in a while with
a structure that actually facilitates
experimenting with new type
of writing is very appealing to me so
maybe the month maybe that's maybe
that's a great solution as opposed to
two years like you said which I'd uh I
don't think I could I think that will
remain a fantasy in my am III I think
they both they're both good for that
social that community of writers
situation just like this the friend that
I'm swapping houses with who lives in
Brooklyn is a grad school friend and I
just you know in my late thirties I was
able to make very very dear friends
through my two years of grad school but
there's an extent to which I that that
like MFA programs aren't really designed
for 38 year olds who are already
successful as writers and then madam
that a month program I mean obviously I
have a vested interest in my own one
month program but a one month program
can deliver both the community and a
more concentrated spark of of
inspiration without having to go through
a two-year cycle that isn't necessarily
tailored to someone in your situation
one thing a two-year program can give
you is structured like monthly deadlines
but if you've already written them look
I think there's an extension to wit's
like that exposure to poetry or fiction
or screenwriting and just 30 other
people who are gung-ho and are locked in
on that similar creative openness that
that one month catalyst can be more
youthful useful in both senses then then
a more extended certificate program last
two years you know it's I I am happy
that you misspoke four seconds and
youthful because in a way I think it's
almost appropriate because like you said
the charge of a group in Paris
recognizing for most of them that it's a
very unique opportunity that required a
lot of sacrifices to make happen would
charge it with a certain youthful energy
which I'm trying to reintroduce the doom
and gloom
just general internet [ __ ] but I'm
trying to beat back my own cynicism with
a club and really try to prevent myself
from becoming apathetic that's a very
strong word but there's just there's a
lot of instability and and craziness in
the world if you go looking for it or if
you are spending a lot of time on social
media for instance and I want to combat
that with a positive and charge youthful
energy so it's very interesting well I
think that that goes back to the idea of
of success versus lack of success and
that a certain kind of success is more
meaningful when you're thirty than when
you're forty because you have a
different relationship to that success
after you've been steeped in it for a
while so finding the screenplay that you
can bang your head up against or
embracing poetry or any or you know
Samba dancing or anything else with that
that vulnerability that beginner's mind
that youthfulness I think that that that
is so useful to use the right word this
time in in rejuvenating your
relationship with yourself just like
when I started as a travel writer there
were certain by lines that were really
important to me that aren't now you know
and bye-bye lines you mean publications
and credits yeah yeah I'm gonna write
for the San Francisco Chronicle I'm
gonna write for National Geographic
Traveler good publications they do good
work but I realized that once you took
away the the the the thrill of that
initial success of having a major
publication acknowledged the quality of
your work then it shifted you know what
what I was doing with the content
I guess transformed a little bit and so
so now I'm writing a screenplay with
with zombies in it not that I'm gonna
become a b-movie screenwriter now but it
brings me joy you know sort of that
childlike joy in the creative process
that doesn't exist anymore
if what I've already become
professionally successful at right and
so I think you get into that pattern and
it sounds like you're experimenting with
this already that you become successful
in a certain manner of creative
expression and a certain manner of
expertise and then I think a way to keep
yourself fresh is to try activities that
you might fail at and I think right if
you aren't failing at something fairly
substantial once a year then you're not
pushing yourself enough and of course
travel is a great venue for inviting
failure and you know mild humiliation
but sure you know I think I I think it's
great that you're that you're bashing
your head against a screenplay that
might not worked out um ten years ago or
maybe eight years ago I sort of had my
vagabonding screenplay where I was sort
of expressing the philosophical ideas of
a vagabonding through a coming-of-age
story and it didn't quite work you know
maybe I'll go back to it but it was a
good thing to have tried and not quite
succeeded at and I'm not saying that
that's where where your screenplay is
going but that process I think is
important for keeping yourself sharp and
keeping a perspective amid certain jaded
nough stew other kinds of success
definitely uh the the the the adjectives
well the adjective successful is come up
a couple of times when you think of the
word successful who's the first person
who comes to mind and why oh man I don't
know if I don't know if a person comes
to mind you know I think when I was 28 I
may have I may have been able to name
like a travel writer that I wanted to be
like Pico Iyer or Tim Cahill and I think
the reason that a person when you ask
that question a person didn't pop into
my head because I have that different
relationship to success you know that
the hunger to be like a Pico or Tim
played itself out in a very in a great
way it became a part of the energy that
made me a travel writer and so now I
don't think you know it's funny I I feel
like our backgrounds are fairly similar
I'm from Wichita Kansas you're from
rings right Lona that's right bullseye
middle-class families it feels like
that's right um and you had your Ivy
League experience right out of high
school and I didn't like I did my I
taught at pan and and Yale for a couple
of years really recently and that became
a part of me felt like I needed to
measure myself against that standard and
it was a great experience but now that
has also been folded into my idea of
success and so I think this might be a
little bit tied into talking about the
creative process and sometimes it can be
difficult that what my notions of
success are slightly different it has a
different energy so I'm not thinking
about someone I want to be necessarily
but it's back into that I think it's
more about appreciation like my role
models and I'm still blanking on who I
might point out are not achievement
people but appreciation people you know
people who have found the success and
are synthesizing it in sort of a good
life kind of way definitely I think this
is just somebody who can't who comes to
mind I've asked this question of a lot
of folks and more more than a few times
Steve Jobs comes up but I he's he's
actually not in many ways exemplary
based on what you just described and I
think Steve Wozniak's co-founder very
much is if I've met woz on a number of
occasions and I even gave him little
tango class prior to his Dancing with
the Stars experiment and the saying uh
he really savers and loves life and has
built has built a life for himself where
he is able to enjoy or experience the
joy of discovery and is the genuinely
happy human being and this is gonna
sound funny but despite all of his
material success because I think that
the material success not to say that
that's a bad thing I think that it
enables more than it disables but it can
become
a it can make people very defensive
where they spend the vast majority of
their time managing protection and
growth of their assets as opposed to the
growth in other areas of their lives and
I've I've certainly I mean I don't have
hundreds of millions dollars or anything
like that but I've been very fortunate
to have enough success with publishing
and elsewhere that I don't have to worry
about where the next month's rents
coming from but I've witnessed that in
myself and I think that there's a
possibility and maybe this isn't true
but I'd be curious based on your
observations if you if you've noticed
this you know coming from a very
middle-class background where there were
many many times when money was tight in
the family and we weren't able to take
certain trips or get certain birthday
presents or whatever it might be
I'd go out to certain restaurants that
my my inclination is to be very to focus
on the the defense and protection of
assets more more than perhaps those
people I met for instance at Princeton
who grew up as Blue Bloods where money
is a known quantity it's it's a it's an
element that for multiple generations
the family is has become comfortable
with so not sure if that's worth
exploring but that's something that I
try to be very cautious or aware of
because I think it's a it's a it's a
terrible inclination that I have well
you touched on a couple of things a
couple of new concepts I've come I've
sort of wrestled with very recently and
it actually made me realize who my who
my role models are gonna be to your
earlier question but yeah it like
teaching at Yale for example which is
such a good institution you know I came
into into Yale in my early 40s and my
excitement at being at this institution
after all these years you know after
being a person when I was seventeen at
the at the college fair in Wichita
Kansas I remember looking at the Yale
table and feeling sorry for the guy who
had to come to Kansas and not even going
there
you know just because I came from a
family that that I'm that you don't
spend money on an Ivy League
education there's more practical ways to
eat your education it wasn't an
expectation but me sitting as a teacher
in a class yeah this is very recently
who's excited about being at this
institution in a way that the 18 year
old student isn't you know the 18 year
old student is just relieved to be there
because they've been expected to be
there for years and it's a part of their
socioeconomic status and they didn't
have to go to their safety school sort
of situation right and and so in a way
that's sort of a gift of middle-class
--mess is that you're not you don't have
those expectations nobody's gonna be
disappointed if you're you don't end up
at Yale and you can actually have this
this beginner's minded experience of
being a 42 year old who's over the moon
about being a Yale professor all of a
sudden and actually the other thing you
asked about when you think of success
who do you think about actually I've
been really fascinated just like in the
last couple months of the stories of
Dave Chappelle and John Hughes Dave
Chappelle being the comedian who had
turned away 15 fifty million dollars in
society sort of said oh what's wrong
with him and then John Hughes who in the
1980s made all of the best teen movies
ever and then just sort of disappeared
to become a quiet person and did he make
home alone or my making that up
he made home alone he made all of those
brat pack teen movies he made home
phones Doubtfire did he also make that
one he may have been involved as a I
might be making that up
but he had involvement with movies
through the 90s and then just sort of
stopped doing that altogether in the
2000s and we and I'm still in the
process of researching this personality
type because I'm really interested in in
the relationship that these guys have to
success and they were both judged sort
of harshly and I think that these are
guys who are really trying to wrestle
with the idea of who they were versus
who their success dictated they were
supposed to be right and so Dave
Chappelle we live in a society where you
have to be insane to turn down fifty
million dollars people were questioning
Dave Chappelle's mental health yeah that
was that was a very prominent feature of
the whole discussion yeah
whether or not he had gone literally
insane when in fact it could have been
and again I'm still researching these
guys that could have been a radically
same thing to do a friend of mine Rachel
Cod's Egon Sethe who is a great
up-and-coming journalist wrote a piece
profiled him for the believer where she
went to his hometown in Yellow Springs
and talked to his Springs Ohio talked to
his mom who's a professor and actually
ran into him in a coffee shop but sort
of wanted to respect his you know
privacy sort of thing right and Dave
Chappelle is a fit happy guy living on a
farm in Ohio hanging out with his
friends and it feels again I I need to
do some more research but it feels like
he's a guy who decided what would make
him happy and he realized that 50
million dollars and getting locked into
a show wouldn't and similarly John
Hughes is a beloved guy and there and
these are two examples there's other
examples that one could throw in but he
was beloved for his team movies but I
think there came a point at which
especially by people of my generation
there came a point at which that he
didn't want to be beholden to The
Breakfast Club and Sixteen Candles
anymore that he he's a family man and a
guy who was passionate about his
creativity and I think he chose being
happy in a city that he loved Chicago
with family members that he loved over
making you know the Breakfast Club three
and making another ten million dollars
and so while I wouldn't say while these
guys didn't pop into my head as examples
of success they're guys that have sort
of captured my attention because I think
the the sort of public perception of oh
here are these guys who have disappeared
with these two examples these guys
aren't disappeared they're not people
who disappeared but they they returned
they realized that they had they had the
the structure in place to live the lives
they wanted to live and they quietly
have been doing that I love it makes me
want to immediately start researching
both but if you're if you're on the if
you're on the job then and I given that
I enjoy your writing so much I'll
probably just wait it's funny but I'm
not researching it from a writing point
of view so you go ahead and
it's just like from an intellectual
point of view you know they were at all
points Heraclitus said you never step
into the river the same river twice
because it's a different River and
you're a different man and that's
probably not a direct quote but you're
always trying to make sense of how
you're living and how other people are
living and suddenly this is just a
random intellectual thing that I
probably wouldn't have thought about in
the context of success until you brought
it up and here's two guys that I think
you know we're crazy like foxes you know
that that said no thanks American idea
of success we're gonna take real success
we're going to take time wealth and live
in ways that make us happy instead of
trying to to live up to artificial ideas
so success so I would actually you can
have it Tim and I want you to be this I
want to read this book or article on the
on success management you know because
it's less management I like it it feels
like an important topic yeah yeah I
agree
especially because it's such a it's such
a nebulous term that I think there's a
there's a lot of insidious potential for
such a heralded pressured nebulous term
in particular interesting all right I'm
going well sure that seed will we'll
just sit in my head and not go away so I
might have to scratch that itch well I
mean if I'm you know so many ways of
looking at perspective and success but
in dental terms were all more successful
than the kings of Europe five hundred
years ago you know right so there's that
the keeping up with the Joneses idea of
success you know that comparing yourself
to other people idea of success is
useful to an extent but it's also toxic
and so it's part of this idea of success
management which is a phrase I only just
now said but it feels like it's the
other half there's a million books about
how to become successful but perhaps
there's not perhaps the idea of how to
manage ones success in a in an enriching
and life-enhancing way is something that
more thought needs to be you know
addressed definitely well this this is
uh this has been a fantastic conference
I have just a few more questions I'd
love to ask I want to be respectful of
your time but I think I'm very hopeful
that people will enjoy this and they
should definitely let us know if they if
they want around to at some point if
you're up for it because this has been a
blast but the the the questions I have
so they're a couple of rapid-fire
questions you walk into a bar what do
you order from the bartender what's what
are your your drinks of choice or drink
of choice I have turned into a into a
whiskey guy and I'm actually giving
myself a little vacation from whiskey
just because almost like with internet
connectivity it became too easy to like
have a nightcap
that compromised my morning productivity
and you know being the middle-class guy
I am you know I love Woodford Reserve
and I'm talking about the Bourbon
e-types of whiskey but Evan Williams
Black Label makes me happy but I'm
taking a little vacation from it because
it became my you know my booze version
of the internet where it just became
unnecessary for me to be having you know
another Evan Williams and you know I
like I like the single malts and stuff
like that too but as far as something
like I needed a freedom app for my
bottle of Evan Williams it just duct
tape over the mouth like an anti booze
pacifier I should sell one of those it's
not it's not alcoholism because I've
been on my whiskey fast for about two
weeks now and I never think about it I
just need to get my monkey brain off of
off of my my whiskey nightcap because it
was delightful and unnecessary and
completely you know counter to my own
creative life you know it was a very
lazy it was like checking my facebook
feed for the third time in 20 minutes
you know anyway eventually I will return
to whisky with pleasure but I'm on a I'm
on a little mini retirement from from
whisky I understand I just took a
recently took a month off of booze and
for similar reasons do you have favorite
documentary or documentaries what popped
into my head is is Verner Hertzog's
grizzly man oh boy have you seen this
I've I have now I've heard of this this
is the one with the I think part of the
reason I may have avoided it with with a
horrific epilogue if I'm not mistaken is
this is this the same movie that a um
the epilogue is well let me let me
rephrase that
are people eaten by bears yes it's about
this this eccentric fellow named Timothy
Treadwell who spends 13 summers I
believe it's 13 summers in Alaska with
grizzly bears and the 13th summer he's
actually eaten by a grizzly bear and
it's something if this is not a spoiler
because you know that from the beginning
of the movie and one reason I like it is
that it's such an interesting experiment
in storytelling and I use this as an
example with my students about how you
infuse narratives with mystery with the
idea that you're going to get certain
information later on in the narrative
and he stand Hertzog gives us the answer
to the mystery almost immediately which
is the what what happens timothy
treadwell gets eaten by a bear but then
it's like the how it gets answered but
then it's the who it turns into this who
the hell is this guy who would hang out
for Grizzlies for 13 summers and and I'm
not saying it's not my favorite or it's
not one of my favorite documentaries
from the standpoint of like sort of life
changing model for how I want to live or
even how I want to make a documentary
but it's such a brilliant use of
narrative a Verner Hertzog is just so
good
literally yesterday I was looking at
like these spoofs of like Verner Hertzog
reading Curious George which it's just
it just killed me it just it was so
funny if you've seen if you've seen
Grizzly Man with his sort of Germanic
voiceover and you hear this spoof of him
leading Julius George was a curious
monkey so it's so uncanny anyway that's
sort of an aside is that he's another
one of these role models of someone who
is so brilliant he's sort of um
look terribly brilliant in the way he
uses narrative and it's such a subtle
and simple and brilliant way of telling
the story of timothy treadwell you
mostly through tim Treadwell's
own video that it's just it's just a
fantastic documentary and it doesn't
really tie in a lifestyle design but as
far as using it as a model for using
found footage and existing resources for
telling a really really profound story
about human nature and the people who
sort of go against human nature and
nature itself and the assumptions of
nature it's just fantastic and yeah a
guy gets eaten by a bear but it's less
macabre than you might think
this is a random one but we mentioned
adaptation earlier if if Nic Cage came
to your house for dinner what would you
cook him Oh God
well I'd probably I'd probably go to all
these and find some cheese bratwursts
just because that's sort of how I roll
you know it would be the same if you
showed up at my doorstep or any number
of friends or celebrities that that's an
interesting guy and this is another
complete aside but I'm a little bit
obsessed with the movie Conair that
requires some elaboration okay because I
saw it on a bus in Syria and that movie
like if you took every if a computer
took every action movie cliche and
turned it into an algorithm and spit out
a movie it would be Conair you know with
a cast full of indie actors I mean Steve
Buscemi is in that movie and John
Malkovich is in that movie but I watched
it on a bus full of Syrians and they
didn't have any of the snarky self-aware
judgmental hipper than now attitude
towards it and they cheered at the end
and they cheered in the middle and as an
and that became a part of my emotional
experience of Syria which and this has
been 14 years ago which is this amazing
place and it's become this heartbreaking
place because I know that the people I
met there and who were so wonderful are
living hard lives now
and so I want to write an essay about
this at some point about my emotional
relationship to Conair that is somehow
tied into the experience of travel along
with for like the helplessness of
seeking what's going on in Syria and
sorry for this to take a serious turn
but it's one of those limitations of
travel you know for all of the beauty of
humanity that I experienced in Syria
which was such a wonderful place years
and years ago that I have his dumb Nick
Cage movie tied in to my emotional
experience of the Syrian people so you
should absolutely right that I think
that be I think that be a fascinating
piece Roger that
so to cheese bratwurst sign me up
what what is the the most gifted or the
few most gifted books in your life
meaning aside from the books that you've
written and of course people who
followed me for a while know that I've
given away hundreds if not thousands of
copies of Ag bonding but and thank you
for that of course of course I think
it's I view it as a must read of course
you know that aside from your own books
what books have you gifted to other
people the most well you could probably
guess Walt Whitman's Leaves of Grass and
and and this is this was especially a
young adult to mid 30s gift and this is
gonna sound funny but I I probably gave
it to every woman I dated for like six
to ten years not because I was some sort
of jaded pickup artist but because I
felt it was so true to my own you know
you know joyous attitude towards how I
wanted life to be and just sort of the
openness like this 19th century gay dude
you know capturing these Rowlf straight
guy emotions towards you know the joy of
life and so I apologize if I sound dated
to my ex-girlfriends but there's a point
at which that I felt so connected to
that book you know that I would give it
to people I was falling in love with you
know and so that continues to be
a book that especially for young people
who are just sort of coming into
wrestling with what's in store with them
for life leaves the rest is this this
great reminder that joy and and openness
to experience and inclusivity is
something that is going to is going to
be that catalyst that makes every every
experience more exciting I love it that
any any others what have you been
gifting to your your girlfriend's for
the last while you know I have so many
writer friends now
that I I like we I have really good
friends from my grad school program who
are poets and like your you have a
poetry best-seller if you help sell 150
books of poetry right and so I've been
buying a lot of poetry by my friends or
even just by poets I respect simply
because that one purchase and hand off
is meaningful to them in a way that
other people might not be and this is
something we haven't touched on but
poetry is useful for non poets in the
way that it uses language you know
there's nothing more pure and distilled
in a way that every single word operates
in poetry and so my friend Eli Braille
just came out with a book I've been
buying that for friends my friend
Heather Heather Dobbins Combs had a book
that came out with poetry and I think
poetry is a good and hopefully my
friends who are receiving these books
are reading them it's just a good
reminder about how important languages
and how much you can do on a single page
with language and so that would be is
Leesburg wrasses poetry too so somehow I
mean this prose writer who's besotted
with poetry for the last 20 years that
that's a big thing to definitely I need
to I need to read more poetry have never
been much of a consumer of poetry
partially I think because I I dealt with
a lot of holier-than-thou liberal arts
majors at Princeton who seemed to imply
that if I understood if I if I insisted
on understanding the poetry that it was
is above me that I was lacking the
intellect or somehow if if I couldn't
appreciate what I considered to be
nonsensical right throws that I just I
just didn't get it
and that I think gave me a bit of an
allergy to poetry that I should probably
revisit it besides Walt Whitman any any
other poets that that you would
recommend to the intrepid reader of
poetry
well actually a guy who speaks most
every summer in Paris is a guy named
Stuart Dashell how do you like was last
name di s s yes c h e ll it's very dude
like poetry I mean is it like a country
song about the pickup and the dog or
what are we talking about
I mean he's from Jersey he's from
Atlantic City okay and it's not dude
like in bro like poetry but it's just
like if if you're a you know like a
straight male who's encountered bigger
questions in life there's something very
relatable about it penguin publishes him
also a guy who was born in Kansas and
who is sort of out there and his poetry
is really infused with a lot of pop
culture is Michael Robbins who wrote a
poetry book called alien versus Predator
it's just a sort of a trip to read in
fact yeah it's a fun book to just read
by and read out loud to your friends
because there's so much he's like using
this these strange meters and rhymes
with poems about Axl Rose you know you
know rhyming Axl Rose with something
else really interesting guy who's also
published by penguin so those are a
couple of dude poets that I think would
be accessible or at least appealing to
people who aren't usually invested in
poetry Billy Collins being another
example these are all men actually
there's a woman named aiming at supa
matado
in easy h UK you m80 ITIL great woman
I've spoken with her at a at a writing
an environment conference and very
accessible and beautiful poetry one
recommendation I might have people for
people who are interested in poetry
which I would imagine for your in my
audience both is maybe not
huge priority of people who will read
our books just get an edition of best
American poetry any any time in the last
20 years and read through the poems and
the ones that you don't like forget
about them and the ones that are
appealing find other poems by those
authors and that's how I found some of
some of my favorite poets that's that's
great advice and I I just wanted to
raise also one other poet and I've and
this is this is one of the rare poets
who broke through my probably unfounded
bias against poetry uh Naomi Shihab Nye
Shi H a B Nye two words her father as a
Palestinian refugee and just really
enjoyed have enjoyed her poetry and kept
it quiet this is so stupid but it just
goes to show how early bruising can
affect how you behave as a supposedly
mature adult right right
I enjoy her poetry because I understand
it it's it's beautifully written but I I
get it there's sort of a message being
conveyed or a point or a description of
something concrete and I suppose I was
based on the condescending lectures that
I would get from people at Princeton who
were probably very similar to the guy in
the bar in Good Will Hunting whose
reciting you know plagiarized classics
just like imagine that [ __ ] and
multiply it by a couple hundred people
up I I guess I've never really talked
about it but Naomi she have Nye as a
poet that I've come to really appreciate
so I need to I need to read more poetry
I'm glad that you're sort of lighting or
lighting a fire for that and those poets
are out there a major Jackson is another
guy it occurs to me african-american guy
from Philly who actually taught at the
MFA program I didn't study poetry but he
was there great guy
and and you know for every completely
abstract poem that's playing with
language in a way that is almost meant
to be pretentious you have poetry that's
very soulful and accessible and great
and people might bag
well people deeply vested in poetry
might bag on the accessible stuff but
there's a lot of it out there and again
the best American series are other
anthologies might be a good way to find
it or even just going to poetry daily
and ignoring the poems that seem
completely inaccessible and following up
on poems that seemed to really be
delivering something relatable Donald
hall is another great one he's he's in
he's pushing 90 now but he's a wonderful
wonderful poet based up in New England
well Ralph I want people to to continue
exploring your thoughts how can they
what is the best way for them to to
learn more about you find you online etc
my author website is Ralph Potts calm
that links to all aspects of my travel
writing career and also my career as a
journalist and an essayist if they want
to know more about vagabonding hay they
can buy the book they can also go to
vagabonding dotnet with which I can
should probably remind them has
resources that go in tandem with the
vagabonding audiobook that you published
and are also more updated than the print
book that came out 11 years ago so
vagabonding dotnet slash resources will
allow you to follow up on a lot of stuff
we've talked about today a lot of these
websites like boots and all and then
finally anyone interested in my Paris
course which takes place in the month of
July every summer is Paris Writing
Workshop calm which is also linked from
my author websites but Paris Writing
Workshop calm will give you all the
basics about that and Twitter is a
trough pots so there's many ways to find
me and that is ralph with an F for those
people who might be wondering what the
spelling is oh and an F we go in an F in
our and T's as well yes Rolph pots and a
few folks who are interested in the the
book club so III do have a book club and
vagabond e was the very first book I
used to launch that book club and you
can hear a sample of the audio book and
and check it out at audible.com forward
slash Tim's books so you
and you can you can get a get a scope on
some of the books that have had a huge
impact on my life and I'll I'll thank
you once again or off because
vagabonding certainly hit me at a very
important time in my life where I could
have gone many different directions and
I feel like it steered me in a very
positive direction and if I hadn't read
vagabonding quite frankly I don't know
if the 4-hour workweek ever would have
been written so so thank you once again
for for having that impact on me and
many many thousands of other people as
well well I appreciate that and I
appreciate you championing the book too
that I've really it's really gotten to
people who may not have found me
otherwise so it's a great synergy
happening there for sure and I will
continue to champion it so rahl thank
you so much for the time and I would
love to continue this sometime when
you're when you're available and and not
taking a sabbatical from from
electronics and until next time thanks
so much for taking the time all right
thank you for supporting the sponsors of
this show 99designs which is your
one-stop shop for all things graphic
design related go to 99 designs com
forward slash Tim to see the projects
that I've put up including the mock-ups
and drafts of the book cover for the
4-hour body ex-officio ex-officio and I
go way back
ex-officio dot-com forward slash Tim you
can see the clothing that I've used for
traveling through 20 plus countries
including the underwear by the way
that's about half of my underwear drawer
right now ex officio com forward slash
Tim you can also see the viral video
that I put out which shows you how to
travel the world with 10 pounds or less
as always you can subscribe to this
podcast on iTunes and you can find all
of the links and resources from this
episode as well as every other episode
by going to 4-hour workweek comm forward
slash podcast spell it all out or you
can go to 4-hour work week calm and just
click on podcast feedback if you have
feedback I would love your thoughts
anything at all who you'd like to see on
this show ping me on Twitter ask T Faris
that's Twitter com /t Ferr is
or on Facebook at facebook.com forward
slash Tim Paris with two R's and two S's
and until next time thank you for
listening